alright next five minute game going
against the International Master from
from Israel yeah a bit of bit of a set
day maybe today for Israeli chest
vendors Baris girlfriend very just by
one half I'm not sure what the
expression mr. to get the world
championship title it was very close in
bow tie breaks against vision on ok we
play on here yeah the check Benoni which
is very close to opening obviously black
tries to maneuver maybe I'm in the long
run get some Sun play with be 54 f 5m h
3 also maybe not the best move thinking
of it maybe a rupee one with the idea of
before was better now we actually
manages to play be five I guess he has
to put talked a bit too much there
that's a bit annoying
yeah okay try this kind of setup which
at least restricts our black's pieces a
bit but it's not what i wanted to want
to have of course gastly yeah it's not
not at the end of the world but usually
have this kind of formation with white
actually being better on the chrome
inside and not like here we can can
argue that black is very fine on the
queenside and ce4 might be a might be a
weakness it takes root before somewhat
annoying idea
and Bishop g5 might be might be an idea
for black
okay try to open up the position here
going for my pieces now you see one I
need to get off this diagonal like it's
most likely fine here these nights are
not doing much but compared to some
other position that black often gets in
this opening it looks pretty okay Carrie
94 I'm trying to attack okay just takes
surprise me okay the bishops are maybe
not super important here what about B
forms before an idea here trying to open
up the position here before
interesting maybe it sounds it's too
direct but okay it's it's interesting
let's go for this way we make some sense
about this rope end the sole
configuration or quick response all
right isn't this quite interesting from
yep i'm not sure why is playing so
quickly let's say d6 now d 6 light we
should be formed this looks I'm fine for
for for me doesn't it I am I just
misjudging this position I mean I'm not
playing a slow as usual but especially
in those first games it's always
problematic ok yeah but now I thought we
should be five this is a bit nasty but
what I thought route the rook f6 would
win here doesn't it win this would be
disappointing yeah come on Queenie have
six bishops is three really wins and
King takes I really cannot believe black
should should be able to survive this
maybe you can but look so scary
I'm or maybe even rooks e7 here could be
an idea yeah my time is an issue of
course okay I need to play with Knight
takes Queen f3 kingi seven bishops III
check he needs to wow so I am always
surprised when people and play so
quickly we were thinking what was it so
bad when I played are also obvious
everything here check
yes is g5 move and then it takes
annoying check
yeah somewhere it's not working out and
everyone you got eight seconds yeah the
position is even good now but with eight
seconds I am I spend too much time here
yeah we're not time of course and i'm
pretty sure this was just winning for
white we check this with a computer this
is even a draw but i'm not sure if i can
make this just move nice check check
check check check wrong are drawn this
is threefold with one second on the
clock yeah but i think it well time
management was terrible but the position
is just winning for white one hundred
percent sure okay yeah this computer
this position already is plus 596 25 is
plus 9 yeah just not on rules would have
been okay this is plus 13 and this is a
mate right yeah this is checkmate I just
didn't didn't saw it just didn't see it
works e7 was stupid yeah bishop see
three wins bishops III king of 7 24 and
and it's over yeah it's not a difficult
I could have seen this yeah and with one
minute yeah bit disappointing yeah but
an interesting game yeah thanks for
watching